what's fair buddy
we're from Finity and welcome to another
episode of challenge mum phonetic this
is the series where you challenge us
with the craziest ideas related table
tennis if your comment gets picked we'll
feature in our next video and give you a
shout out so make sure you leave your
comments and ideas in the comment
section below
so Allah wants us to play with rocks
it is my weapon and Miko animal can
challenge me with this this wouldn't be
so hard
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
just recap analysis
[Applause]
[Music]
this one's from leo so Hans Libya Hansen
he wants to see us through 60 shots each
under one minute I'm sure we'll do it
under 50
[Music]
so that 120 shots
[Music]
now it's time to play with this chainsaw
let's go
[Music]
stop
[Music]
therefore empanada mean if
[Music]
[Music]
thanks for watching guys hope you
enjoyed it if you have an even crazier
item we should play with in the next
video leave a comment in the comment
section remember to subscribe and watch
our previous episodes here until next
time